Speaker 1: . Let's go next to Itti from
one of my favorite cities in the world,
Copenhagen, Denmark. Etai, you are on the air.
Speaker 3: Hi, David, it's good to speak to you.
Pleasure. All right, so I have a hypothesis
about why American politics is the way it is,
OK, and basically it's this the American electoral
system allows us to have basically Dewhirst allows
both parties to be basically unaccountable
and still win, because if you look at it,
technically speaking, the rules are that you
only have to perform better than everyone else,
sort of individually. We call it a single
winner system. And that actually guarantees
that you have a two party system like
you have in America where you have.
What is it, a party like the Republican Party
that's just a cult now, and I think that if that
is really the main problem with American politics,
Speaker 1: so let me see if I understand. So
basically what you're saying is no matter how bad
Republicans are or get in terms of being radical,
in terms of being a cult, in terms of being
unhinged in any particular election where they can
claim to be slightly less bad than Democrats, they
have a shot at winning. And that's a real problem.
Speaker 3: Yes. Yeah, I agree with you. I
mean, yeah, in Denmark, we use something called
proportional representation where the amount of
vote you get is proportional to how much people
support your opinion. And I'm
thinking just it's it's kind of
miserable, that abysmal that we live in or you
people in America have to live in a system where
they're not able to have a different option,
because the way the American system works is you
only have to get a plurality. You don't have to
get more than you like. If you get a really huge
number of votes or if you have a lot of support,
your idea won't get into government. Like if you
look at the the percentage of people in Congress
that support or oppose something like Medicare for
all. And then you compare policy in Denmark and
you compare the how the government, the people
in government, the parliament, support or oppose
the policy compared to the population as a whole.
It's there's a very strong correlation, but there
isn't in America because the system just allows
the worst kind of people to win elections.
Speaker 1: Yeah, this is just a feature of
the first past, the post plurality system that
we have. You know, in some cases, you actually
do have to get a majority. So if no one gets 50
percent, there's a runoff. But OK, we can put that
aside for now. You can have a district where 45
percent of the population wants Medicare for all.
And forty five percent of the voters vote
for the candidate that wants Medicare for
all. That candidate loses and the
representation of that district,
which is forty five percent for Medicare for all,
is only one elected official who does not support
Medicare for all. That's just a fundamental
problem with the system that we have. It's a
there's no way around it. It's just the way it is.
Speaker 3: But if we use the Danish system,
of course, I think they would the
Republicans would never win another election
or maybe they would still have supporters,
but they would never be in office again.
Speaker 1: Well, hold on a second, because with a
system like that, you could also have Republicans
from some of the minority Republican districts
that are only represented by a Democrat right
now. I mean, there's two sides to that.
Speaker 3: Well, I guess, but at least we
wouldn't one product of the proportional system
is that you actually have like a multi-party
system. We'd at least know where people stand,
because I know that there are people who vote
Republican who are actually have populist
opinions and would probably vote for a different
party if they had a better very choice to go to.
Speaker 1: There would be Democrats also who might
vote Green Party or something else as well. But
I think it's a very, very interesting proposal.
Listen, we keep reading about how great things
are in Denmark, 75 plus percent vaccination,
or is anybody wearing masks anywhere at this
point? Not at all. No masks and things are OK.
Speaker 3: Things are great.
Speaker 1: Wow, wow, I really miss
it. It's really Kopenhagen is such a great city.
The biking, the bike lanes, the food is fantastic.
It's just so great, you know?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I love it.
Speaker 1: Well, I hope to get back
there soon, I appreciate the call.
Speaker 3: Thank you, David.
Speaker 1: When I say there is Itti
from Copenhagen, Denmark, what a special
city, what a special city, my friends,